hello everyone happy mondays to everyone
a solo stream today I'm Eric and I'm
gonna play a anime game today the seven
deadly sins not on to note I see I'm
probably saying the last word wrong but
Knights of Britannia it came out last
Friday from the Namco Bandai we're gonna
start a new game I only did like two
missions there was a lot of chatter that
I saw earlier for in the in YouTube
saying like there was interest but
people are scared or maybe not scared
might not be the right word but curious
about what the gameplay looks like and I
played a little bit and you're gonna see
what I saw and you guys can make a
decision yourself on if you want to play
the game obviously if you watch the
anime there's probably gonna be a little
bit more of a draw here for you to play
the game I think it mainly goes through
first season of the anime second season
is like running now things on like
episode 5 oh no he's a bit
tell me soon you like this they're also
people cushioning if I would actually
get the pronunciations right of the
names hopefully I do meliodas title
[Music]
oh I was pretty close on the Tizen Tizen
[Music]
all right of course the holy nights are
causing trouble so she needs help from
the seven deadly sins like all this part
is like totally good and fine until we
get to combat then you're gonna you're
gonna see what's up a talking pig that's
right bio will
that's hawk don't you know he's a
strongest the strongest member uh yeah
the stream started should have you guys
should be good and everything alright
some nights are trying to capture Liz
can't let him do that I think it runs me
through tutorial here a little bit so if
it does apologize which I could fight
its hawk I hope I hope at some point and
get to fight his hawk all right cool yep
progression yeah here's all the buttons
if you're curious there's magic there's
attacks it's kind of like in some ways
you know if you play it Namco Bank icon
and anime style game it's got some of
that like Naruto beat them up can do
magic at some point be little combos
oh no there's more bad guys I'll try to
I'll try to get through some of this
pretty quickly see if I can they're the
magic so yeah this is what the game
looks like though there's you know we
can track him with - you got kind of
like the moonshine with Mirage Mirage
step behind every card in the game but
you can like you know do that like like
I said almost a cog ablution he only has
a sword hilt because it's kind of like
broken it's part of like you know
anything about the enemy is part of like
a a thing that's like that used to be on
to seal a lock away it's like part of
part of that lock but it like has like
almost like an invisible like blade in a
way he has full counter of course if you
watch the enemy it's like one of his
like special news
I dashed right through them sick you
lowly Archer one punch one punch man I'd
play a one punch man game actually I'm I
actually really want to play the the
boku no hero Academy game that looks
good
combat doesn't look so hot says tee
Khalid yeah like all this stuff looks
good like the cutscene II stuff or like
the in-between stuff looks good but the
gameplay itself kinda looks a little and
I think they did a better job of hiding
it a little bit with like Naruto cuz
it's more like associated a little bit
it's just my my opinion on it all right
cool we're on that word we're going down
the main questline that was the first
mission now we're gonna fight we go like
the Knights boss guy who isn't he's also
part of the enemy furious right here we
go it's definitely Elizabeth dude I
would totally how would they do it one
punch man yeah that's true I don't know
maybe you plays genis and why would you
kill the princess I'm just a young I'm
just a young lad as we are Emma said and
Massacre I think seven deadly sins are
not as unit Isaiah is on Netflix price
season one dude fighting on there yet
because it's in process season two seems
interesting different different art I
don't want to spoil too much
also there is dual mode in this so it's
not just a single player kind of like
story as you go through story you'll
unlock characters you can duel as or
against twee go being one of them yeah
he's not like the lackeys dude come on
man the other anime game I'm interested
in checking out is the the new one-piece
one that one looks pretty good too wait
who knows his back is shown to us oh wow
turned out he's pretty buff I guess he
really wasn't like the lackeys he'll
actually block to you unlike the year
what do you ain't got nothing against uh
my Mirage step I guess so there's the
Guardian
oh how did that not combo
from above with this morning I wish I
could oh TG off the ground but nope oh
well throw I got hawk backing me up
always good
mmm-hmm we gave them the the fake out I
forgot how to do the super I should have
read the tutorial try nope that was
different
oh there was crap please attack me
I got him got him with the revenge
counter we got it man I hope i unlock
like bond or DNA alright I find the
other six deadly sins obviously wants to
hire her star power
you know ff4 de says looks like the
attack on titan game attack on Titan
series coming out this the the game is
coming up this year too as well
nope it was fate
pretty much cyborg I mean like a lot of
a lot of the anime agates see like I
don't get how I got an S there but I got
to be finding the Knights Massacre has
got a some that's either a cat or a dog
with heart eyes for Dianna do you own a
normal size or giant size alright let's
see I haven't done anything past that
mission so see what happens here bor hat
is there like home location there pretty
much you know HQ it's a bar
I agree Hawk millio this is pretty
unreliable I might have been read by
Nature it's kind of weird that I didn't
have to unlock it but uh you know he's
always about having fun
alright
as mentioned we've got tweaked oh we got
the forest as a new map for duels we
could probably check out duels later but
we'll go through story for a bit as
mentioned the stream name is the first
hour of this game so helping hand oh no
we got to gather materials
bio-oil stop it I kind of play as
Elizabeth I gotta grab some materials
alright hock let's go find some I feel
so reassert reassured that I have hawk
as why is my bodyguard Oh fetch quests
ok 0 of 6 oh she actually has an HP
gauge oh you can send that Hawk to
attack alright alright get out my way
huh yep mm-hmm I got I got what we need
I need two more of these I'm faster
Elizabeth what's that oh that's the edge
of the map
oh my god invisible wall nope
she's missing a stocking nah man it's
all about them style points side work
man hawk strongest of all yep I don't in
eating he is probably the strongest of
all if you've been watching season 2
it's actually Oh No
okay if you watching season 2 it's
pretty hilarious because like Merlyn
pretty much gives him like the ability
to have like a Scouter and he can read
like power levels and she like lied to
him about his power level we did it yeah
fetch those quests
did I get an s for that or was my timing
poor yes yes ring baby s rank and uh I
picking up stuff there they're saying
that Mellie Otis is a terrible chef
which is true that's why we need bon bon
Summa oh my magic items sweet hey I'll
go pick that stuff up
no no side quest oh so many menus oh we
can we can like our thing can like
travel no all right let's take a look at
equipment now do we have anything
Oh Mike what is all this there's so many
items wait can I even I came aware that
yet okay I'm guessing we got out unlock
that stuff even Hawks got his own all
right that's cool I'm guessing we can't
make anything oh oh we can't make
something okay so this is this is part
of it all right so give me a magic
bangle I don't guard 10% HP boost a hawk
if you just want to go ham on hawk boost
ilysm no hell no man 5% all right
whatever we'll just can we make this way
not like this
maybe not okay I'm stupid maybe I'm
stupid I can't I have the necessary
crystals interesting whatever not gonna
question it can't can't do any more
quests though so I guess we got travel
somewhere oh yeah there's a field quest
there's side quests there's main quests
magic creation okay let's see magic item
gathered gather ingredients and magic
crystals needed to craft yep create a
magic item unlocks the adjacent magic
item yep mm-hmm where was the button to
actually make it magic crystals he
breaks up yeah it was in the tree I
didn't pick one up I think Oh so
completing some side quests or few quids
net see you ingredients for crafting the
magic items that's good all right
oh we got to go to who the Forester
puncher do you think bonds over there oh
why do we gotta go there first
why can't we go to the forest look I'm a
giant pig I really made it to baño
oh the holy nights for cousin problems
it blocked off the water I think that
was in the anime too I recall correctly
it's been so long since I watched the
first season because there's been like
what two three year gap since season one
and two of course he was able to do it
oh let's go beat up on some nights I
guess he can't read he doesn't have the
ingredients really I thought it said I
did have the ingredients maybe I
couldn't read thanks Firebird mute I'm
not sure Adam pool if there's English
voices I guess I could check in the
settings after wait didn't we do this
I like when I fly right by them let me
get a B at this rate you win Oh blade
flash
nothing like beating up on some lowly
nights maybe a doll mock like the guy
that's their boss I was like a c-grade
effort right there I know there is a
definitely in season 2d gripper oh five
it's on episode five so yeah I'll double
check it was flashing red although check
on the the gear oh I'm s Oh more rumors
we need rumors yes he's so like there's
definitely something in the forest I'm
gonna guess it's like another deadly sin
yeah we're gonna go to the forest yep
I'm enjoying
I think this Ark's gonna be pretty good
dr. gaming like the first season was
kind of to flesh out like you know who
they are how they you know we're
together and stuff like that kind of
bringing them back together this time
around it's like what's that do we get
that
all right main quest all right so let's
go back into here because I can't read
apparently yeah missing the gem splinter
thank you thank you and slight leftovers
I can make this one though right because
it's green but why do i why would I want
to make that hmm oh maybe we want the
beasts claw though huh
or the I started the power bangle all
right let's just sure oh we gotta make
this thing oh we can make this thing too
sure oh we're just unlocking stuff now I
can't make that though all right we need
we need some more items which is fine
there we go guys I crafted something
thank you to the chat for helping me out
the serpents in of Mb seat like the
thing is I know their names I'm assuming
that's bond
which how big is the pig which one hawk
or the giant one the giant one's huge
the one that it's like a lot bigger than
an elephant in terms of like how how it
looks like in the anime look hawks for
you 100 rocket beat up Oh No OMB is
Dianna oh thank you
I forgot which ones they are in terms of
like this actual sin I just know them by
name no we will not leave this force
does he say that every time I feel like
that I feel like he does oh there's a
lot of them it's forest people rush do
what's that
it sound like a heel jam probably was so
I guess you want to destroy as much at
the environment as possible to get that
I and hot gems cut trees down break
houses that work a right bond is greed
Thank You Joseph thank you Steve only
want to play his King group huh club
made for some good baby back ribs and a
lot of others
oh it's DNS Emma she loves Melly notice
Millie honest though I'm not a holy
night don't you know your Don Cho I'm
the captain
how did she pick this one she still has
like okay there you go I'm Joe
and jealousy is gonna start to happen
probably UFC OBT non-dna don't you know
Adam pole that's part of the anime man
we need go there to go through okay
nope this is like Zelda hurry
next screen next grade eventually she
gets human-sized
I think she might need Merlin's help for
that though that that's a while for now
what hey look its DNA yeah mm-hmm yep
well maybe we get to play as DNA oh
we're gonna fight guilt under everyone's
favourite Titan
I mean oh now that's a holy night or
about to be I don't know if Merlin and
Leona's I seen them in the title screen
Bob so I would assume so but I don't
know wait is guilt under the sisters
boyfriend I think yeah you knew him as a
kid
gimme I think I think Gil Thunder is her
sister's brother our sisters like
boyfriend or whatever hey you're not bro
you're not stronger than a seven deadly
sin I don't want to fight you
we're buddies
okay so Fox sin of greed is definitely
bond so we got to free him from the
prison I want to see is sloth go through
where's that King I know you guys can
help me out
yes Steve diamond says Elizabeth's
sister whoever not cool got that one
right haha tricked him
King is glutton okay so yeah is probably
go through them all right let's see how
Gilboa Duty Bull does don't block we're
just gonna Mirage I'm just gonna rob him
I think okay you like he was facing the
wrong way
oh hey man I was trying to grab a
diamond oh my god he has lightning
attacks
that's right
why can't I combo off that oh wow okay
there's other gems in play that do like
area effects stuff I guess
oh good after him magic spells
[Music]
now he's almost dead
yep you can't block forever goat there
is goat sin of lust and who is a king is
king sin of saw man all right who do I
trust here cuz then okay we'll figure it
out
Harlequin is sloth Harlequin is also
king just so people know if in case like
someone else calls him Harlequin be I
deserve that it's about right one punch
man season to win I think it's this year
what's up hailstorm Reaper is this an
open-world game really Merlyn is
gluttony okay wait really okay I think
Joseph has been on point so far so Melia
okay here we go Millie Otis is Wrath DNA
is and the event bond is greed king of
sloth both there's lust Merlin is
gluttony s canora's pride I I don't
think we've ever seen s kannur right I'm
not fully caught up on season two so
maybe he's in he or she's in season two
but
oh so we're gonna go save bond probably
or so it seems
i unlock yield thunder for dual-mode I'm
just good oh we got travel thank you Bob
and everyone else for telling me the
who's who is it this way yeah we gotta
go get our boy bond look at a pervert
Mellie Otis though from the back thing
yep of course we did in the manga I
haven't read the manga though mad Schism
so SK Norris coming season 2 yeah I
would I could see that yep as hell storm
Reaper said in the manga but hasn't
shown up in the anime yet thanks
everyone
appreciate that yeah we're pretending oh
yeah we're gonna drop the hammer I was
just gonna just recomm oh man Oh chief I
doesn't ever hammer yet huh yup does it
hurt
this is like the reverse of attack on
Titan you are the type let's see what
she has a magic spell wise oh my god
this is
oh just step on him yep mm-hmm
just me Rance our triangles seems to
just be like
but I'm squishing that earth element
boom Eskin or is the store on gist says
Shahin Zargon yeah you don't want to
mess with DNA you're not a true fan if
you haven't seen the manga is that is
that true I guess I guess that you know
what Maureen I guess that's fair I will
say usually when I watch an anime if I
can't wait to watch another season
I usually gravitate to reading the manga
so like for me I'm reading hero academy
weeks a week I read food Wars week to
week and I read some other stuff that's
like more like monthly but yeah when
manga is very good yeah I'm sure it is
it's like 200 something chapters though
like I'm really far behind probably come
on Gophers purists even here says uh
Norbury sorry I put your name there Eska
noir has a find a mustache
sometimes you need a DNA smasher you got
to travel through do we not just open
the okay oh man the prison so far away
[Music]
there's a lot of forts to go through why
do we have to go there
thank you bypass it No ooh trial six I
regret reading one punch man monger I
spoiled it for myself that's what that's
all right
I can't play this DRA come on we found
her already
yeah Wheatley that's weird so there's
that venture mode where you go through
the story and you do various things that
kind of fall in line with the anime
manga but there's also a dual mode that
you can like 1v1 in that's another like
what you might call it's like a option
playable option and as you get through
the story you unlock more of the
characters you can essentially play as
in the dual mode as well as a like
arenas or maps or whatever alright Hawk
can apparently block you from where you
need to go
it's a lot of generic yelling Oh
get him Hawk butt smash oh we got row
row row row Noah in here one piece the
only thing I need to read too good not
to
- that's like 900 chapters I couldn't
keep up with that that's that's insane
one piece is really good though it's
it's a kind of amazing that it's still
going on with kind of just the main
plotline it's not like a Naruto where
went chipping in and stuff like that but
he does have to become Pirate King so I
guess that makes sense are all the Ten
Commandments in this game I don't know
llama robot if you guys don't know who
the ten commandments are they're in
season two so watch season one then
watch these in - I think seasons who's
gonna be pretty great though it's gonna
be more like oh your typical anime where
you have like big fights and stuff like
that one punch man one of the was it one
of the greatest enemies despite the fact
that there were not many episodes made
yeah looking forward to it I'm kind of
worried / curious how oh you have to
play us ha how the season 2 is gonna go
especially since they changed like
production studios I think cuz like it
was gonna be the same guys that did one
point for the first time who also did
mob psycho blanking on the name of a
company right now but kind of curious
how it's gonna go
now that they're switching this Hawker
magic oh he does oh the butt smash
forgotten meal
rolling ham attack baby
just haka barrage oh my god he has it
are only it's one person do we need
rolling ham to hit more than one person
not doing it
look I got I got tricks - oh God oh come
on bowling ball to him
can't hunt this this boar too strong I
can't change that camera angle once it
doesn't lock on oh this old man wants me
to beat these Knights up for 20s we got
that for 20 attacks keep giving them for
20s I'm only gonna for 20 M
[Music]
all right is that getting boring for you
guys I find hilarious there oh no we
didn't kill enough people is it cuz I
was fooling around oh my god I failed
okay all right I didn't know you could
fail how do you too much fun all right
we gotta beat 60 of these guys as fast
as possible maybe I should just focus on
the archers cuz they they get one shot
but maybe you don't get the archers to
show up unless you kill the heavy duty
guys alright we got to focus huh it
turns out Hawk has to actually try a
little bit or we won't pass this mission
I'm too used to Mele Otis and his like
Opie attacks look at that look at a
dashing speed and bison type attack well
maybe I should be forgotten kneeling the
big dudes because they are not dying to
these other weaker attacks
[Music]
I feel like I'm gonna fail again because
[Music]
this guy should count for like double
auto hit no wait oh we got a hurry I
don't feel like I'm averaging one kill
per second Oh
Oh gotta stay away from that No Oh 12
more gotta find the archers quick six oh
no three more guys four seconds
no no why would you okay
turns out this is gonna be the hardest
this might be the hardest mission all
right we're gonna have to pass this we
have to pass it well we don't have to
but I have to for my own sake
please stop this violence
hilarious that this so far has been the
hardest thing to accomplish though
almost not worth using his magic because
it's just so we 420 attacks
okay he's got some combos though whoa
what was that
[Music]
a little foot snap
how that move sucks he sucks against the
heavily guarded guys
okay well we're doing better because
there's only 12 now right got a beat up
on the loli archers
hawk please
Oh No we failed again quickly ah ah
we're short by one this is stupid
oh crap I meant to do it again
let me try that
they does not do well as a pig now
apparently
maybe look maybe the key is beating up
on the bigger guys first alright gotta
focus okay maybe maybe maybe I'm wasting
my movements to main attack
Nisha's saved that lightning we have a
long combo right now
come on Huck
oh my 37 hit combo now the dream is dead
No
dang it misses it that attack
oh we're so close
No is this just our destiny to miss it
by like one every time what are we doing
wrong alright alright
this is the last try I promise but I
don't know what I'm doing wrong
it has to track before I can do the -
combo or the - move
oh come on that was part of the 40 hit
get off me I'm the king of leftovers
every time I say I think we got it I sit
so I'm just gonna not say anything this
time
got'em Oh finally hak-sun we did it that
took way too much effort I am the head
of scraps disposal as those true
damn right we better have gotten an S
I'm just gonna skip through some of this
talking harder than Dark Souls now
should not be the case all right we got
a new quest but I'm gonna go say bon or
hopefully this is where we say bon woo
so is this the original story or based
on the anime I feel like it's more based
on the anime Brandon I haven't done okay
not do this what there you go
wait don't let me do it interesting
and I guess we just got a beat up more
people and do that tamale thing maybe
okay after struggling with hock I'm just
not gonna do that I guess I could have
been hock and then Mellie Otis could
have been me the support there hey they
finally said something new did we beat
these guys up ready
okay go back to town okay we'll do DNA
with some kind of like sideways eyes
it's based on the original anime and
manga though I think it's heads on a bit
further past season one and into season
two make sense because I did see like a
kind of like silhouettes of the ten
commandments that make sense
who would counter Islam or robot yeah I
need to pull off of I need to pop one of
those maybe he wants me to go to Damali
DNA ooh we have to play his DNA yes I
have no wounds up passed out yeah it's
too early to be streaming no it's not
it's almost 12 o'clock that was
lunchtime but I've never her even heard
of this game it says rear axle it's a
new game came out Friday it's based off
of the anime anime and manga seven
deadly sins not a student I say out from
by Namco I don't watch anime games this
year
attack on Titan twos gonna be out this
year hero Academy I think is out this
year for getting some others we do have
an article gate spot that's shows off
all the anime games coming out this year
also a video on youtube of all the anime
games coming out this year oh she's got
protect millio dhis yeah well you're
also like you're a Titan and they're
like little peasant Oh step on him Oh
strong hand
oh no the house I'm so sorry
oh you know just an earthquake oh how
did that not hit the other guys one
punch
how's that not it is I like how they're
like not even hitting here the
destruction has to end
no I'm here to destroy houses and stuff
like that
get stepped on I wonder when I get the
hammer whoops it's like one punch man
it's like part of the reason why he
can't like he always has so much
destruction that he like makes no money
the doctor tries to etosha highschool
DxD season four is coming out as well is
it is that this year dream fighter
hey I followed that one as well crazy I
have a 99 I love this anime don't worry
you guys are so screwed
you got blackmailed got it
no problem he doesn't break promises
that was weird she said his name twice
in two different tones how strongly I
don't know if Deanna should be called
the heel of justice or the stiletto of
pain are those stilettos though oh I
watch kono Suba - Eric do you see my
pitch for rap battle anime I did not so
the game is the same as an anime story I
think so crazy Ivan there might be some
stuff from season 2 - but I haven't got
that far so I have no idea
haven't watched anime in years sister
axel was the last one you watched do I
know the way my brother no I don't know
jr. maybe these are normal old-time
shoes they're more like like boots you
know oh we get a dragon I'm fine
like how hocks like nostril kind of
flares it was not that much so jealous
DNA does he have a girlfriend this early
vehement I don't like season two he's
kind of got like the Lackey that can't
stop long also River says most anime
gamers are rarely English dub mostly
Japanese sub yeah I'm not oh yeah I was
gonna check that for you guys
I'll check next time we're in the bore
Hat
all right they'd hit the other
a lot of magic is probably why I can't
Oh
yeah we did it
has anyone got a full metal alchemist
vibe from this anime really personally
uh enemy freak says they're supposed to
be 10 commandments are in this game as
well but I don't know how much of that
is true yeah I'm not sure I haven't
gotten that far in this game obviously
and if it is based off of the anime /
manga there's a long ways to go before
we even get to that arc cuz we haven't
even found all the seven deadly sins yet
we have two out of the seven but I did
see their silhouettes in the game so I'm
sure they're in here at least to kind of
like it makes sense because the anime
for season two is out it's kind of like
this would help lead you into the anime
or watching the anime there was someone
else that also saw you the same way DNA
you just forgot all right this is where
she talks about how she's you know not
the same size you know as Elizabeth
she's jealous then now Elizabeth wants
that they wish I could switch
that is true Steve King is a fairy that
isn't rub with the enemy can't make that
like that all right can't make anything
right now just fine
oh wait let's look at settings all right
so text you can turn on English and
that's it you can change the language
turn yeah there's no changing the actual
nope I guess we can't travel maybe to
the prison yeah so I couldn't change it
to English dub
all right fox sin of greed let's get
barn out of their bond just makes me
think get back the anime you guys watch
that one it's good one I liked it all
right we got her we got our chef this
game is out a phantom gardener came out
last Friday so can I touch her booty
with meliodas no I can well I guess we
gotta fight bond to get his respect how
do we get both get hit by that magic
whatever it was damn he's going ham on
me
but I am the captain after all so
get rekt bonds
oh man he's giving me the combos come on
give it to him you would think that
would do way more revenge counter should
do more than 800 damage come on man
or maybe I'm doing it wrong maybe I
gotta wait for them to attack and then
do revenge counter if it's that complex
nah cyborg man the thing is there's a
backstory they like fight each other all
the time so it's not like so much that I
beat him up to get him to join it's just
he likes challenging Mellie Otis that's
kind of true Adam pole pool sorry the
combat in this game is similar to
j-stars victory vs I have heard the same
thing I did not play that game but I've
seen some video of it so that looks like
a finisher it's a I think it's a super
mom come on
yeah look for King is there a black
clover game coming out as well I've been
watching that anime - llama robot it's
kind of filling that Naruto Bleach s
kitsch I guess I think it's fine as I
still watch it weak to eat black clover
that is goop saying goop shoo ride
saying feels like all the anime games
are hacky / yeah it's pretty true that's
a fight him again you don't want to see
him mad
can I fight them again oh I'm bond oh
crap get none shocked
oh crap don't spam Oh what was that I
did like a like almost like a counter
behind him and then it didn't plan oh
hello
Oh snatch like an actual grab Oh does he
have - - man bond is sick getting buffed
up here Oh throw a rock at him oh he's
full countering me block it oh yeah
that's right it's like based off of the
damage he takes right it does more based
on his uh his damage okay whoa whoa he
he tried to he tried to get me there
Danny I was dangerous I haven't played
it Ian
t-bone I'm now played ninokuni -
fortunately so I can't help you out in
that regard
whoo he built up all that damage on me
crazy stuff oh yeah and then there's
gonna be a sword art online the the GGO
arc the gun the fact that almost counter
strike go arc except he still uses the
sword of course
yeah I lost 75% well I'm pretty sure it
was like either revenge counter or
something because I did do about that
much damage to him so then that might be
how Mele Otis is a super it works it's
all the built of damage right doing
requests we got travel having gone that
far Steve but I like bonds like story in
general though like what he's had to go
through and why he's kind of doing some
of the stuff he he does gun Gale online
you know
GGO kind of excited for that uh new
sword art movie okay
myself okay let's go you don't know
oh no get out of there
physical hunt of [ __ ] it
okay so snatch is like a combo extender
physical hunt probably gives me the like
the buff it's weird that okay so he
doesn't have what appears to be like
your normal like - can only good chase
down that try to block see what that
looks like
does he have a super oh he died on the
other side of the wall dang it you get
to try it
who is my favorite sin and ask a mere
host in a miserably hopefully I said
that right sorry if I butchered it oh
man that's tough I actually I think I
like him I don't know why but he is like
sort of fairy king and yes Bob you're
right technically speaking bond should
never lose in this game yeah okay we
can't go there
what is up game boys art 19-point cowboy
77 hello how are you doing thanks for
tuning in thanks everyone for tuning in
we are live every day at 11 a.m.
gamespot live you guys oh look we can
run an errand let's run an errand as
Elizabeth we're live every day at 11
a.m. you play various games one of the
games we've been playing a lot week to
week is Monster Hunter world with Ben
and John Luke that's moved to Friday I
think we're gonna try to check out some
tree fighter cost okay is Hawk supposed
to protect me from all of this I got a
dodge okay yes ha protect me while I
pick up this stuff
oh I can jump I got a back - where Hawk
attacks damn hawk the howcome hawk
doesn't work like that
as an AI but I can't use them like that
for crap yeah whatever
plant a playin anime Monday's no it's
not true I mean if there's enough games
sure right I'm definitely gonna try to
check out some of the other don't you
dare try check out some of the other
anime games coming out oh crap okay hit
hawk I'm the princess Oh No
okay you can only get hit twice oh dang
it her run animation oh yeah alright we
gotta be scared more careful I suppose
[Music]
why would you send her out here to get
this stuff when there's so much danger
going on there
okay so she can only get hit twice I'm
better off almost laying hawk just
attack on his own because clearly me
controlling him is doing no good there's
a bunch of anime lovers in the office
but I don't think anyone has watched
this anime other than me you need to hit
him right now thank you
no need you over here hawk
or
just spam triangle oh that almost hit me
what are you doing
hit hit that guy okay oh this could be a
mistake no what are you even attacking
Hawks
hit that hit that guy Oh No okay okay
there's this one guy left you oh those
two guys left oh wow he is whiff whiff
City over here all right cool we good we
good we good
had to be way more tactical there than I
thought I would oh man I've never seen
that durian I'm kind of sad now that I
don't know that he does that that's fine
that's fine
oh look Danny's got a new animation
she's just chilling now will you be
streaming sword art online fatal bullet
Astri kooky - um I will I will try - for
sure we'll try - when it comes out I'm
gonna do a couple more of these missions
and then probably call it a oh yeah
could be bond now why can't I pick DNA
she must be like Opie or something in
the beginning like you probably can't
even like play her as like the big
version except for like certain story
missions
do you know who you're hitting right now
whoa he winds that move up like crazy
why are you lying on the deck
who he has liked the people's elbow
oh now he has a - with that
no bleach is alive in our hearts okay
let's be real here for all the people in
chat cuz I know you guys all watch anime
I feel like we could have stopped bleach
when he sacrificed everything and beat
Aizen and we could have is good we
could've been great but no we had to
extend it into like all these like extra
arcs for what reason why like why
exactly see hellstorm is saying in chat
what I just said pretty much how do they
know what Merlyn looks like like dude it
was so good when it like like the first
arc of bleach was like really like I
don't know maybe maybe the progression
and stuff is always good leading up to
like getting stronger because even like
I would say one piece like starts off
like really strong too and then it kind
of gets like not so not so hot later why
can't I engage in it alright pick that
up I guess we got some more missions we
got to do something trial 28 out of 26
oh you got a fight as what yeah oh you
gotta fight both of them wait what's
what's past this dreamer can you play
with the best girl
unfortunately I can't can't I can't play
as any of the girls right now
what reason asked one piece money yeah
but the thing is at least one piece was
still good as you continued that but
bleach just like it didn't get better
just like Naruto though stretch it out
if it's popular at least with that there
was still like an end game to that right
like you knew he wanted to be Hokage so
at some point he was probably gonna be a
Hokage right wears like bleach who was
he like
what was the end game for him what was
the what was the endgame for Kurosaki
Ichigo hmm was it is this fun anime game
Vitara its kind of fun I think you would
have to have watched the anime enjoyed
or enjoy the anime to really want to
play this game though I don't I wouldn't
say it like hey go pick this up to play
this game I would only recommend it to
people that have either have interest in
the anime manga or have watched it
before because otherwise oh yeah hey
it's our it's our boy potentially
because I would say if you if you have
money to spend I would like tell you to
at least there's a couple other games
potentially that would tell you to get
instead of this one but if you like the
anime and you want to relive some of
that some of the story but via a game
platform then this would be definitely
the way to go
I kind of feel bad feeling beating up on
some dog some dogs here but he's kind of
like a Opie
so I mean I don't feel terribly bad
because he's not really like I don't
know hard to explain
don't call PETA on me please I'm
technically honest just like break these
boxes
there's only one left
all right well Ichigo has been given the
title of the protector as well as dark
protector I believe I'm sure what's up
with the pig talk he's like in charge of
the scraps and the leftovers so the
black hound is kind of like part of king
in a way think he's technically what the
pillow
[Music]
okay so you know passed here now and we
have to go to get to King though it's
over here this is one capital fort now
if I gotta bust this thing open soon
maybe oh we can't do it yet though got
to go to town Raleigh
Tehan me oh my god we just fought these
guys
I just wonder if you have to do these to
get to where we need to you know another
anime or manga is still read that was
kind of old is how do you may know Ipoh
but yeah that one's taking a while it's
like almost 1200 chapters I don't know
which is like crazy my khalasar
how do you do like one manga for like
that long
oh you know it's interesting as an anime
that I watched is Bakuman cuz it's like
an anime based off like two guys that
become manga like faders that was like I
don't know if that's actual like
legitimate insight but that was kind of
cool
you
ah Riku key - says what other anyway
would you like Bandai to make would one
punch man game work I don't know if it
would work somebody I said something
like that earlier but then they're like
how would that even work I'm like I
don't know cuz he would just destroy
everything like he would beat everyone
like I don't know if you can make that
into a game necessarily hell you can't
even really make food Wars a game like
how are you gonna do that unless it's
like overcooked where it's like can you
cook faster than the other person so
it's almost has to be action-oriented
and they've always covered most of the
games that are like or anime that's like
action-oriented right attack on Titans a
game start our own Eliza a game boku no
hero Academy's a game one piece is a
game bleach was a game Naruto is still
game Berto is probably gonna be a game
Oh King and Bond I think once we if we
can get King I think that's we're gonna
add me so yeah so I feel like most of
the anime games that you could think of
having a game is gonna be a game
oh and Drago all fighters awesome game
obviously especially if you're into
fighting games and if you like Dragon
Ball of course I mean what is that
no Gintama yet that's true that's true
randomly says Bachmann is pretty good
same people that did that know Death
Note was good I like the first 26
episodes and then the back 26 I don't
care about do not watch Death Note
Netflix here's King if you guys didn't
know he's like the fairy king or was but
technically if you ever see is a wanted
poster it's like the fatter version of
him all right
does he know his spear coz what is he
without it oh my lord he's got magic
though get snatched oh I tricked you
crap he's got the he's got that magic
though
you know that rocking them mu4 floating
in the air though
Oh No do King is so buff and the pillow
I believe as much oh he does have the
spear
Oh super they come bow into it
what do they do
Oh did I just get buff
oh yeah I feel fast everything
going ham no oh it's cuz No
well I guess that's his like you can
grab them dude bonds I'm too strong too
strong even though King would probably
win I'm sure the right the spear
transport engine pillow some flour and
other stuff yeah damn ssj mode let's see
I missed it
oh yeah speaking of live-action Japanese
movies full of them
Full Metal Alchemist hitting Netflix
19th of February at should be pretty
good
what's up William McBride
yeah I'm looking forward to potentially
watching full metal alchemist actually
so I got my girlfriend into watching
anime more recently lately maybe I can
get her to watch afternoon I don't know
maybe he lost a lot of weight
yeah because that's not it's not real
king I guess you'll get it alright let's
see if we get to play as king I don't
know if we will gonna skip through some
of this is this on xbox I'm not sure
actually
I want to go to the Necropolis nope only
playstation ps4 exclusive as anime
freakin Luigi we need to help unload you
land of the dead yeah I remember Ellen I
don't remember Luigi though Oh a comment
got kill that's a good shout llama robot
that would be sick I wish that and I I
finished reading that one I finished
reading that manga I wish there was more
anime that was that was sweet
well fairy tale that's true I stopped I
read I read fairy tale as well I
finished reading fairy tale I never
watched the anime i just read the manga
kill la kill could work as a as an an
amiga
I think a gamma I got kill and fairy
tale would probably work better but yeah
let's see we can make any I'd almost oh
you make that so I guess like we should
just make everything right that we can
nope can't make some of this other stuff
so there's equipment list I don't think
I have any of this nope I think a Lulu
nope I think Elizabeth has something oh
here he has equipped okay great
whatever uh all right let's see if we
can play as King if not then I don't
know Death Note have you seen that yes I
watched all 52 episodes right but as
mentioned I liked the first 26 episodes
a lot better I feel like the cat and
mouse game that was going on was really
what drew me in to Death Note and once
that kind of cat-and-mouse game ended I
didn't feel as compelled to watch the
anime did you like anything that bleach
did like the Blancas or the Espada I
liked a lot of bleach leading up to the
Aizen Arrancar Ark and I thought that
they could have ended there and just
been good with it and then everything
after was just kind of like yeah yeah
okay I guess
ooh Soul Eater that's another good one
yeah there's too many there's too many
animes so leader is like a pretty pretty
old one there you could you could also
argue d.gray-man
potentially nothing to fight him again
okay with boys came damn
crud
how many times can I guess I can only be
snatch like once
that could be four meter to do the
superpower
[Applause]
whoa
come on give them that
whoa people's although I know a lot of
people want a one-punch man game I just
don't know how it worked don't know how
did I get here I'm from Germany
I don't know project X but I'm glad
you're here yeah but you don't know the
true story King it's all your fault
he thinks that bond is the person who
potentially killed the holy maiden who
is sister there's some more background
there and I don't want to spoil it if
you don't know anything about it it's
pretty important though part of the
story
alright I'm just gonna see if the next
course lets us play is as king if it
doesn't then probably gonna call it ice
cream there oh well you get to fight as
guila or you get to fight against Kela
who is also okay this is the last this
last mission 100% heal is part of
important part of the story too
she's part of pretty important to it
they can season two a little bit because
of what go thir tries to do how does she
expect to be two deadly sins impossible
should we let her like beat me up a bit
so we can see if that counter thing
works the way we think of these
like I play better as Bond
oh okay she got some Madhukar i underst
not actually that's good though we want
her to do this up
yes please hurt me that's why I hit me
with it I don't know what it is hit me
with your super oh she drop in a meteor
okay that that hurt a lot let's see if
we can hit her with the let's see how
much she does he's gonna give it back to
her oh it didn't hurt nearly as much as
her super but all right
whew that's a close one with Kela so
yeah oh yeah berserk yeah please Rex
Goodwin to Mele Otis is such a pervert
yeah I mean it's part of his character
dang she is a crazy girl that Kela
that's right all right just want to say
again we are live every day at 11 a.m.
streaming various types of games I'm
sure we'll play more anime games as they
come out there's a couple more for sure
coming out this year so stay tuned to
that thank you guys all for tuning in
come back tomorrow as we'll have another
live stream fun fact it could actually
potentially be destiny to only because
the crimson doubles or the like their
Valentine's Day event is tomorrow I know
that's not necessarily everyone's
favorite but you never know if so come
back tomorrow obviously I'll be here
William McBride I have seen Helsing I
liked it a lot
you should watch all the OVA is the
latest ones if you haven't cuz they're
really good and he fights crazy people
yeah and if you liked Helsing
you should watch drifters because
they're it's I believe it's done by the
same people and it's very reminiscent
except it's um like uh was it Nobunaga
and then back kind of like in that era
but it is very eerily like reminiscent
like in terms of animation style stuff
like that - Helsing anyways but yeah
come back every day this week will be
live at 11:00 as mentioned and yeah
thank you guys for tuning in thanks
everyone for hanging out today whose
you